en el último vídeo vimos que si teníamos
su mercado con competencia perfecta y si
a corto plazo actual un precio de
equilibrio estaba por encima del precio
necesario o por encima del presión que
las empresas estarían generando una
ganancia económica luego entonces más y
más empresas se empezarían a introducir
pues la ganancia económica es positiva
lo cual significa que es un buen lugar u
oportunidad para usar tus recursos para
tener un buen costo de oportunidad y así
estarías haciendo una ganancia quizás
más allá de tu costo de oportunidad
entonces más y más gente estaría
entrando al mercado así que después de
un poco después de que una compañía
entre o tal vez las mismas empresas
empiecen agregando más y más millas a
sus asientos en el caso de la aerolínea
o agregando más aviones con lo cual
tendríamos más oferta a corto plazo y la
curva luciría algo así por lo que
entonces tendríamos un nuevo precio de
equilibrio que sería un poco más bajo
y también una nueva cantidad de
equilibrio que sería un poco más alta y
lo que sigue es seguir manteniendo tu
precio de equilibrio pues fue más alto
de lo necesario para tu ganancia y
entonces sería cero para tu ganancia
económica
y para que más personas entren todavía
tendríamos una nueva curva de oferta a
corto plazo y nos movemos más hacia la
parte inferior derecha de esta curva de
demanda y todo esto pasa hasta que
tenemos la curva de oferta donde el
precio de equilibrio en esta nueva curva
de equilibrio a corto plazo es el mismo
que el precio al que todos están
haciendo una ganancia normal o el precio
necesario para tener el cero de la
ganancia económica tener un punto de
equilibrio es por eso que esta línea de
aquí la llamamos como nuestra curva de
oferta a largo plazo pues está
dependiendo en si el precio en
equilibrio va para arriba o baja pues en
algún punto la oferta va a entrar o
salir del sistema así que nosotros
eventualmente regresaremos a algún punto
a lo largo de esta curva a largo plazo
ahora todo esto suponiendo competencia
perfecta donde hay muchos competidores y
productos idénticos lo hicimos para una
forma fácil y sin barreras de entrada
pero pensemos qué pasaría si tenemos
exactamente lo contrario a la
competencia perfecta
así que empecemos en el mismo punto
empecemos justo aquí así que vamos a
empezar con la curva de oferta verde así
que en lugar de muchos competidores
tendríamos ahora solo un competidor
donde obviamente no habría productos
idénticos pues sólo habría un productor
y un competidor enormes barreras para
entrar nadie más podrá entrar incluso
puedes decir que son tan grandes que
nadie más por ley tiene permitido entrar
a este negocio y obviamente es ventaja
definitiva para competidores existentes
es el único que gobierna la
participación permitida y la información
del precio no nos importaría mucho pues
es único y es un precio viniendo de un
competidor ahora cuando hacemos esto
cuando hablamos de un competidor que es
único en el mercado no estamos hablando
de una competencia perfecta estamos
hablando de un monopolio es un monopolio
y es la misma palabra que quizás has
escuchado para tu juego favorito de mesa
y el punto de dicho juego de mesa es
quedarse con todas las propiedades de
los mismos colores por lo que al menos
en el marco de
juego monopolio lo que tú puedes hacer
es juntarlas del mismo color e incluso
subir el alquiler y entonces lo que
estarías haciendo aquí es tratar de
abarcar todas las propiedades tratas de
asia un monopolio cuando tienes un
monopolio puedes luego cobrar más y más
alto a quien quieras por estar en tu
terreno y algo muy similar va a pasar
aquí ahora nosotros tenemos solo un
competidor y digamos que el precio de
equilibrio es más alto que el precio que
necesitas para tener cero en la ganancia
económica y entonces dicho competidor
está obteniendo serias ganancias
económicas bien pues ellos pueden
situarse ahí pues nadie más puede entrar
no vas a tener esa tendencia donde hay
más y más ofertas en el mercado hasta
que tengas una curva de oferta a largo
plazo dicho aquí no va a haber una curva
de oferta a largo plazo la curva de
oferta a largo plazo es cualquiera
finalmente es un monopolio y tú decides
cómo quieres que sea si esto es donde
sus ganancias son no óptimas ellos lo
harán de hecho ellos pueden ir incluso
en contra de esa dirección tal vez
piensen que ya hacen suficiente ganar
económica y quizás determinen o digan
que pueden incluso hacer más ganancia
económica si bajan la cantidad de oferta
aún más por lo que incluso podrían
llevar a cabo la oferta fuera del
mercado y entonces luciría así su nueva
curva de oferta y este sería su nuevo
precio de equilibrio elevando sus
precios aún más y luego tendrías un
nuevo punto de equilibrio que está por
aquí y una menor cantidad de equilibrio
así que claramente cuando tienes un
monopolio no está pasando algo tan bueno
para los consumidores ellos tienen que
estar listos para la alza de precios que
actualmente no es muy eficiente porque
la cantidad óptima no es está
produciendo y sería interesante que lo
pensarás pues los monopolios ahora no
tienen que preocuparse por las personas
que van a entrar pues tienen bajos
precios y tienen esta línea de ganancia
normal y no tienen de qué preocuparse
por las cantidades pues las pueden
acomodar como ellos quieran y la
pregunta sería como lo establecen cómo
determinan qué tan larga será la curva
tal que ellos puedan poner tales precios
limitados por la producción